قال رئيس سور الوزراء الهولندي ماركرو
تاين بلاده قررت سينفاق مليارين ونصف
الملياري يورو بشكل اضافي في اطار
المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا واضاف انه
هولندا تنوي الانضمام الى برنامج بيتريوت
لتعزيز النظام الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
كذلك مع حجم الولايات المتحده فسيكون اكثر
من 50 مليار دولار لدينانيه للانضمام الى
ما تفعله الولايات المتحده مع المانيا في
اطار مشروع باتريوت لان نظام الدفاع الجوي
في اوكرانيا هام وقد بحتنا ذلك مع
المستشار الالماني وبانسبه الى المحاسبه
لا يمكننا ان نسمح ابدا لبوتين وروسيا
بالافلات من المحاسبه اذ يجب ان يجلبهم
الى المحكمه
وقال الرئيس الامريكي من الولايات المتحده
وهولندا تسعيني لحمايه القيم الديمقراطيه
حول العالم والوقوف بحزم مع اوكرانيا واكد
بايضا خلال استقباله رئيس الوزراء
الهولندي ماركروتا انه يتطلع لاستجابه
اوروبيه متجانسه بشان الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا
الديمقراطيه في العالم ونقف بقوه مع
اوكرانيا ونتطلعه الى ان تكون الاستجابه
الاوروبيه لما يحصل هناك متجانسه روسيا
تواصل التصرف بشكل لا يصدق